الموظفون ممنوعون من استخدام ادوات الذكاء
الاصطناعي فهي تهدد خصوصيه الشركات هذه
احدث سياسه لمؤسسات كبرى باتت تخشى على
خصوصيتها من الذكاء الاصطناعي صحيفه
منعت الموظفين من الاستعانه ببرامج اشهرها
التابعه لشركات منافسه وخوفا على تسريب
معلوماتها السريه فبرنامج مثلا عباره عن
روبوت محادثه متصل بالانترنت تم تدريبه
على نطاق واسع من البيانات ليتحاور مع
المستخدم ويقدم له اجابات تفصيليه وهو
يطور نفسه باستمرار استنادا الى معلومات
المستخدمين التي يحتفظ بها ويرسلها
للخوادم الرئيسيه تسريب البيانات
ظهر للعيان في شهر مارس الماضي عندما سمح
البرنامج بالخطا للمستخدمين بالاطلاع على
محادثات اشخاص اخرين واغلق على اثره
البرنامج لفتره وجيزه